the talks were meant to bring an end to
the conflict in Libya and be a
diplomatic victory for Russia and Turkey
but after general Khalifa Haftar left
the talks in Moscow without agreeing to
a long-term truce
they appeared to end in failure speaking
to media a day after however Russian
Foreign Minister Sergei Lavrov played
down the outcome saying the peace plan
put forward by Moscow and Ankara was
still a work in progress
representatives of Libyan society met in
Moscow with the participation of the
Russian and Turkish foreign and defence
ministers we will continue our work on
this track so far there has been no
definitive outcome Libya has seen heavy
fighting for months the country's
internationally recognized
administration the government of
national Accord led by FAA's sahaj is
based in Tripoli it's facing a power
challenge from general halifa koftas
rival administration based in the east
of the country in the city of Tobruk
pufta's forces calling themselves the
Libyan National Army are reportedly
being assisted by Russia and regional
allies Egypt Saudi Arabia and the UAE
meanwhile Ankara along with the United
Nations is backing Tripoli's government
of national accord earlier this month
Turkey's Parliament gave president a
chip type Derwin the greenlight to send
troops to tripoli and after the Moscow
talks failed to offer a solution on
Tuesday other one provided a clear
warning Doddridge in the coming days we
will be closely following the choices
that the coup plotter hafta and the
country's legitimate government will
make in the event that attacks against
the country's legitimate government and
our libyan brothers continue we will
never refrain from giving after the
lesson he deserves now the focus moves
from Moscow to Berlin German Chancellor
Angela Merkel has invited top officials
from a host of countries for peace talks
on Sunday in the hope that this time
around something might be different
and for more tonight I'm joined from
London by honest elgu Monti he's the
head of the Sadiq Institute that's a
think-tank focusing on Libyan affairs
honest it's good to have you on the
program there is I want to talk about
this conference in Berlin in just a
moment but I want to remind our viewers
there is a legitimate government in
Tripoli at the moment supported at least
by the United Nations yet it is under
siege what does that say in your opinion
about the UN's ability to secure the
peace in Libya well the UN Framework by
the Security Council is ultimately
broken in Libya it was the UN that came
in in 2011 when it when I gave its
mandate in 1973 in 2011 to bring around
its responsibility to protect doctrine
it led the calls internationally to
intervene in Libya to save civilian
lives from Gadhafi after the abbé Spring
started in February 7 there 9 years
later almost we're talking about a
situation is radically different
it is the UN Security Council's
framework which is broken and there's
been many allegations mainly leveled at
Franck's for having supported discreetly
helicopter since 2014 and 15 during the
second civil war and they're not allowed
to sanction him or threaten him or
condemn him ever since that moment so
the UN Security Council's framework and
the framework that is supposed to
resolve conflict and defend and protect
civilian lives has really been
threatened by the example of this latest
Oh me distill this down force if we go
back to 2011 there was this belief the
Arab Spring was beginning there was this
belief that something good could happen
in the Arab world and in northern Africa
the US President Barack Obama he put the
resolution to the UN Security Council
and intervention took place and it did
not work the way it was planned do you
do you want to venture an explanation
there what happened was the
international community then too naive
slogans alone Benally these things would
result in
or manifest change all on their own I
think slogans were one thing but
programs when really significant change
beyond just the head of the state
because those states have really deep
tentacles and and that is element of
what has been going on across the Arab
world where you have the deeps there is
the remnants of those former regimes
those networks as political economic and
security networks as patronage networks
how you govern a country beyond just a
figurehead how you deliver security and
almost disenfranchised many of your
population those things no one had a
clue about how to solve them let alone
the local populations that had rose up
in different cities and then we saw in
Egypt that it returned so autocratic
regime in 2013 attempted in Tunisia a
dozen and 15 in Sudan very very recently
as well there's been a crackdown so
you're sort of seeing Arab Spring people
perhaps those moments dozen 11 were
somehow different but it doesn't mean
that people have kind of given up on
this on this spring because I think
there is really a movement those things
that kind of go out of fashion the
danger is not understanding the way that
those things have been put to bed
because ultimately when you look at a
place like Tripoli today in its war over
the last nine months you have this small
little flickering flame left of
Democratic aspiration there is almost
going to be extinguished but not under
the pretext of putting down the Arab
Spring human rights or freedom of
expression or freedom opposition those
things are you know they're difficult to
put down you can't and they're T
fashionable for you to say that right so
what has happened is that there has been
a movement called the
return to authoritarian stability and
that has come at a great expense across
the Arab world and especially and back
in 2011 you know as I said earlier in
the program Germany did not support the
UN resolution the no-fly zone over Libya
was something that Germany did not want
to participate in and it proved that
that Germany despite all the criticism
was probably right at the time in
looking towards the future and now we
have Germany this coming Sunday trying
to mediate some form of peace but we're
talking about nine years between 2011
and today is a European countries
efforts to bring peace to Libya too
little too late
I think we have to really look
internally and there's a lot of
soul-searching at least take place in
Europe because there are so many things
that could have been done but we brush
it under the carpet and we get here nine
years later one thing that Europe can be
very very easily and very very you know
with inadequate political will is to
enforce the arms embargo you can only
fight if you have arms and weapons being
supplied over the last three days alone
since these Moscow talks have ended
there have been huge shipments from the
UAE Special Forces Base in Abu Dhabi
going to eastern Libya that has given
someone like behalf though who left
Moscow knowing that he had their backing
to go fight now if the UN or Germany or
the European Union it's trying to
enforce an arms embargo that would force
the local players to have no other
options but peace but you need to make
peace let lucrative and you have to make
costly it's not it's easy to say nine
years after the fact that somehow it's
better to not vote on these things
because for every situation in Libya you
know the worst one like Syria well you
have genocides that were like like in a
render
twenty years ago and sometimes AB state
you know abstaining from these decisions
it's not gonna make them go away
I'm sorry there's a feed of feedback
here and I'm sorry about that let me
just ask you there what about the
credibility of the German Chancellor I
mean it's it's it's clear that Europe
and Germany don't want another migration
crisis like we had in 2015 and they
don't want one coming from Libya which
would explain why they want to do
something in Libya does the German
Chancellor in your opinion is she the
one leader right now who has the
credibility to get people to make
promises that they will keep Germany has
a tradition at least no interventionist
policy at the very least if neutrality
is not being called into question at any
moment given the announcement at this
Berlin conference from over a four
months ago so I think it's it's the
adequate forum but the question really
is and certainly angular Merkel is you
know it has all the credibility that any
world leader should enjoy when they're
trying to host the conference like this
but the real question is is there
adequate political will in Europe that
could emanate from Germany and emanate
from that meeting because to be frank we
could have had this meeting
Skype my months ago the participants are
all members of the international
community they don't need visas to get
to the gemenese the question really is
are there members of the International
me
someone to solve the speaker's there's
any one thing that you can deal with
fear and fear is easily manipulable you
know it's something that could be
manipulated by other actors seemingly
like Russia could you know could
continue to manipulate the situation and
use the migration crisis to create more
fear about the question is that is that
out of a political will
yeah and you're right it could have been
as simple as a Skype video call but it
wasn't honest good money joining us
tonight from London and as we appreciate
your insights tonight thank you